hola un saludo nosotros somos la perla y
estamos aquí en france24
[Música]
tres mujeres de bogotá que cantan y
tocan a ritmos tradicionales del caribe
esa es la fórmula de la perla un grupo
que nació en 2014 con su participación
en un festival y desde entonces estas
artistas apasionadas nunca se han
separado logran mezclar el sabor de las
gaitas y de las tamboras con un toque
más urbano introducido por el beatbox er
rap algún natural para estas chicas de
la capital colombiana que estrenaron
tabaco un sencillo en honor a su ciudad
mientras esperamos el disco callejero
carencia nada roberta muchas gracias por
compartir este momento con nosotros en
france 24 bueno me parece difícil de
reducirlas a un estilo de música
una o dos etiquetas porque entre la
gaita
merengue la cumbia el bullerengue el rap
el beatbox o sea tocan de todo y
entonces como podrían
definirse y explicar su música en su
biografía de instagram por ejemplo está
escrito expertas en poder ponerte a
gozar eso sería un punto de partida sí
pues digamos que a nosotras en nuestra
escuela es la música tradicional las
músicas tradicionales de la costa caribe
pero digamos pues también hay que tener
en cuenta que nosotros habitamos aquí en
bogotá que es como un centro donde
llegan llega mucha gente de muchos lados
no solo de colombia sino también del
mundo entonces como que confluyen muchas
músicas a través nuestros sí nosotros
pues cada cual desde su casa o desde su
cotidiano escuchamos diferentes músicas
que es lo que todo todo lo que nos nutre
esas influencias y pues a la hora de
componer y hacer la música estamos como
abiertos a que todo ese panorama se deje
ver entonces tenemos los hitos de muchos
modelos y somos de clásicas diría yo nos
gusta pasar por muchos tipos de
sensaciones tocando nos encanta el punk
el rap
improvisar el freestyle pero pues son
los mismos elementos los que usamos los
que hacen que sea original la propuesta
porque de algo muy muy básico y
tradicional pues hemos logrado explorar
muchos diferentes ritmos y sonoridades y
la música que hacen hoy es el resultado
de años y años de investigación roberta
tú tienes una formación de sociólogo
siempre explican también las tres
entrevistas que estudiaron los sonidos y
los ritmos de la costa del caribe porque
en lo que acaban de decir no vienen de
allá vienen son de bogotá va y esta
manera de acercarse a la música es lo
que les diferencia de otros artistas al
final
si total digamos que nuestra inspiración
si son los sonidos tradicionales pero
digamos que bueno aparte digamos como es
música tradicional como que no hay una
escuela donde uno vaya y se forme sino
la escuela realmente es como no sé de
los festivales la región los maestros
entonces como que todo hace parte de
nuestra escuela y nuestra formación pero
digamos que a partir yo creo que más o
menos como el segundo tercer año que
llevábamos juntas como que ya que nos
comenzamos a abrir de esa línea de la
música tradicional y desde que
comenzamos a tomar ese rumbo y como
apostarle a nuestras composiciones
propias entonces como que cada vez los
hemos ido soltando un poco más y como
atreviéndonos a experimentar con cosas
distintas y hay muchos grupos de bogotá
que y de otras ciudades que tocan gaité
que tocan música tradicional y que han
innovado alrededor del sonido de las
músicas tradicionales
hecho fusión o nuevas propuestas de
músicas colombianas con las músicas
tradicionales pero ha sido muy chévere
ver como la perla con ese formato como
pequeño
y crudo porque no le metemos bajo ni
nada raro más que los tambores y las
voces entonces ha sido chévere porque a
la gente le ha gustado cómo está como
esa crudeza por decirlo así como esa
cosa tan raizal o tan tradicional
mezclada con todos estos otros elementos
que te llevan pues a uno a un sonido
diferente incluso para nosotros desde el
principio pues como que no creíamos que
fuera tan posible hacer un ensamble solo
las tres no para nosotros también era
porque pues también por toda esa
historia y esa investigación de los
formatos tradicionales en el formato de
gaita vienen seis personas a veces los
de bullerengue 20 personas entonces para
nosotros también fue todo un reto y es
un reto poder estar como con los mismos
tambores que se utilizan
tradicionalmente están explorando otras
sonoridades y poder lograrlo y durante
todo el tiempo tener como a la voz y a
la percusión como los dos elementos pues
centrales de la propuesta
[Música]
el l
bien
vivo
canciones callas
[Música]
mi intención es cambiar
bueno hablando de bogotá justamente cuál
es tu relación
con esta ciudad en la que se encuentran
y conviven todos los rincones de
colombia su música refleja también su
experiencia en esta ciudad en particular
sí sí claro bogotá es un lugar muy
particular porque cuestiones reúne
muchas formas muchas cosas es un poco
caótica y digamos que yo siento que a la
final también como que nosotras somos
muy bogotá tenemos mucho a bogotá porque
tiene como muchos estados y pues
tratamos como reflejados en la música de
hecho que digamos ahora sacamos una
canción nueva que se llama bogotá es una
canción precisamente que resume un poco
de la
y un poco que está por decirlo de algún
modo muy movida muy muy muy rara y que
significa tocar acá para ustedes en
bogotá pues no es muy lindo pues también
que puedes ver ver a la gente y que la
gente nos vea también en el proceso
porque pues nos han visto también como
en todos los estados no desde tocar
música más tradicional a ya proponer
nuestras canciones entonces y ver que a
la gente le gusta conocer nuestras
canciones y las canta pues nos da una
alegría también infinita que la gente en
bogotá esté reconociendo se también
dentro de estas sonoridades no tan
tradicionales pero pero se reconocen
como propios un poco y en sus canciones
hablan de situaciones sociales y
políticas pienso en temas como el
guayabo como que pasó también donde
dicen por cantar mis canciones que
hallaron mi voz qué papel siento que
tienen ustedes como artistas mujeres
colombianas pero también como artistas
de manera general al utilizar su arte
para denunciar injusticias
así pues en especial digamos que estamos
viviendo en un país que tiene muchas
problemáticas sociales y pues desde el
arte y desde la música que es lo que
nosotros hacemos pues es como que es
nuestra manera nuestra voz nuestro
aporte como a todo eso ese movimiento
que yo creo que se debe generar para
generar un cambio pues entonces ahí está
nuestro granito de arena pues creo que
nos vamos nos hemos dado cuenta del
poder catártico y transformador que
tiene hacer estas canciones como que
sentimos que hay que usar esa voz que
tenemos como la atención que la gente le
da ponen nuestra música para decir cosas
importantes entonces obviamente no le
cantamos a todo todo lo que se nos
ocurra bienvenido pero pues no podemos
hacernos las ciegas ante esta realidad
tan cruda y tan impune que vivimos y es
muy chévere poder con la música también
como también darnos un poco de alivio a
nosotras ya toda la gente que vive es y
ese es el papel del arte también yo creo
un poco no como dejar una memoria
histórica también de lo que está
sucediendo y como dice diana pues no nos
podemos hacer las locas y ciegas frente
a tantas cosas que pasan y es importante
que en 50 años no se cuando se escuche
se sepa que seguían pasando matanzas y
muchas injusticias y que la gente se
entere después de a veces de pronto la
música puede ser un poco más cercana
para entender como los mensajes
[Música]
que arde
está caliente
[Música]
y ante otro muerto apareció su familia
no y ahora el estado los vatos tengo que
viendo hay amor
y cuáles son los temas en particular que
quieren defender en su música son muchos
le hemos cantado la libertad de las
mujeres pero no sólo de las mujeres sino
como de todos los individuos cómo poder
elegir a la diferencia a la tolerancia
el respeto a que no queremos que
devastan más la selva amazónica que fue
nuestro último sencillo a la lucha
social a la resistencia de la gente en
las calles al cuidado personal y mucho
también como el otro al cuidar la
naturaleza a los campesinos vecinos sí
que es muy social no es como no queremos
solamente digamos sólo por el hecho de
ser mujeres que es obvio
digamos ser unas abanderadas del
feminismo que está por supuesto como
dentro de nuestras temáticas pero no es
solamente ese nuestro enfoque porque
pasan muchísimas cosas más en el mundo
que merecen también pues ser reconocidas
y discutidas entonces si nos interesa
mucho poder hablar como desde una
crítica social de lo que pasa y también
le cantamos a la libertad de las
personas y poder elegir lo que consume
si somos activistas del cannabis y bueno
en realidad lo que lo que nos nace lo
discutimos y decimos queremos cantar
sobre esto y va cerraron su cuarta gira
en europa
llamada la cura a finales de noviembre
españa portugal
alemania francia suiza como les fui como
recibió el público de allá su música
bien colombiana al final muy bien
siempre nos va muy bien si otra digamos
como que yo siento que es esta música
que hacemos estos instrumentos como que
movilizan mucho a la gente es bueno ese
energía así como que siempre la gente
así no sepa bailar terminado moviéndose
y contagiada por nuestra música y pues
estuvo genial todo el 2 lugar donde
llevamos 11 de público siempre
demostraba algo de conexión con nuestra
música incluso la barrera del idioma no
ha sido impedimento para que disfruten y
logren sentirse como identificados
como conmovidos por lo que cantábamos y
nosotras siempre pues contamos todo el
rollo de lo que pasó en colombia y mucha
gente muestra empatía y bueno ya la
música los pone como dice karen así a
bailar y es una cuestión muy muy bella a
ver cómo responden la perla fue un
placer muchas gracias
[Música]
pero